it's really cool to be representing that
community in such an awesome action
kick-ass road The Walking Dead star Tom
Paine opens up about his character Jesus
confirming he's gay was it hard getting
close to anyone neighbors friends
boyfriends what was it like for you to
finally be able to confirm that he's gay
I loved how that was handled I knew that
it was never gonna be like a huge deal I
mean listen it's the end of the world
and you really think we're gonna be
worried about things like that I knew
before before we filmed it and because
he's in the comic books and I didn't see
any reason why he wouldn't be in the
show and I spoke to Kirkman about
anything yeah it's the same same guy for
comic book creator Robert Kirkman and
executive producer David Alpert
showcasing diversity on TV is crucial I
think representation in all forms of all
media of all types of people is
something that as creative people we
should always strive to do as a creative
person as somebody who's getting to tell
these stories getting to do these things
it's something you're absolutely 100%
obligated to do so it's something that's
very important to us and we're very
happy that we're able to you know have
this really awesome gay character on the
show that people can look up to and also
the storylines aren't about him being
gay it's not the focus of his character
he's so much more than his sexuality
just like people are in real life
[Music]
you